cet endroit est ma réputation mon magazine
un sang un la fumée se dissipe Je
te promets uma BTK elle fera des images de sang
partout rien de tout ça tu avais des
trous de balle dans sa chemise comment n'a-t-il pas été
touché mes coups de fusil à lui seul aurait dû
te tuer  tu es incroyable, je ne veux pas
être différent de n'importe qui d'autre, les gens ont
besoin de toi
sachez de quoi tout le monde est
capable il n'y a rien qui puisse
vous blesser
alors de quoi diable avez-vous peur Oh
playboy à gros sous votre temps est écoulé
attendez gang ce qu'il faut les rooks c'est dingue
c'est la reine vous avez tous été touchés la nuit dernière les a
pris près de tout le monde  J'ai compris que tu as besoin de lui
prendre le cul tu as signé ça avec nous et
tu presses ne sois pas un héros
un autre type de héros me semble
que c'est ce que tu as toujours été
maintenant t'emmener à la guerre tu n'as pas
assez de gens que tu veux  certains
je suis temps pour ce problème vif de Luke Cal
non mec c'est toi
oh mec PLO Styles ma joie à l'époque
doux Noël tu double XL façon addy
tu homie
toujours pas sûr de ce que je suis je vis juste
ma vie au jour le jour tu devrais être
là pour aider les gens que tu penses que j'ai demandé
Benitez je mettais un réservoir comme
des poissons exotiques avec des capacités Je
veux juste qu'on me laisse tranquille mais
ce serait un gâchis
le symbole culturel de l'espoir et de la
prospérité
[Musique]
trop de choses se passent dans l'ombre les gens ont
peur de ce qu'ils peuvent '  Je ne vois pas
[La musique]
place notre réputation
Je mélangerai notre sang chaque homme d'affaires le
serre fort
tout le monde veut être le roi parfois
si vous voulez la justice vous devez l'obtenir
vous-même
donnez-nous l'argent je n'aime pas votre ton que
vous avez  ma parole madame je vous ai eu d'
une ville ce qui s'est passé je ne dis pas que
je suis américain
j'ai créé des accolades que nous avons accrochées dans cette guerre
mondiale maintenant vous emmène à la guerre vous pourriez être à l'
épreuve des balles
Mahalo
mate c'est censé représenter notre  espoirs
et rêves tu dois te battre pour ce qui est
juste tous les jours
pourquoi ne nous dites-vous pas simplement votre nom
Oh le quartier jappe sur la façon dont deux
crétins ont été battus la nuit dernière
J'ai entendu dire que c'était quatre gars